hello and welcome to world stories your
international reporters magazine im sue
me so Miss Conda and this week we're
going to find out why cars are blooming
in Bulgaria what shea butter means the
local communities in Mali and we've got
a tip for students heading abroad Chile
is the place to be all that and more but
first to iraq in 2007 a car bomb ripped
through mouton nabi street in Baghdad
killing dozens and wounding many more
the attack left one of the Capitals most
historic districts in tatters Moo tanabe
Street also known as the street of the
booksellers was a place where literature
have been celebrated and shared for
centuries a place lined with coffee
shops and stationery stores much of that
heritage was lost but the community has
worked to rebuild since then in our next
story Fidel al-hajj from Al Arabiya
introduces us to one of the most
important bookstores on mo tanabe street
where generations of iraqi history lie
in the hands of one man
Oh
time has not been kind to Baghdad's many
historical monuments and buildings
developers wars and their aftermath have
taken their toll but here in this
bustling market booksellers have been
plying their trade for as long as anyone
can remember and one of these premises
has been in business for nearly a
century the current owner diligently
collecting anything and everything to do
with Baghdad's past both in words and
pictures sseth like that vividly fulfill
ebook sharp opened here in nineteen
thirty in medieval times this was a
paper market now it's known as a Soraya
that's at the end of mutton avi street
in the part of the city called Hasan
Pasha as I said what home my father who
say you know if you Philly started the
business he was famous for his
collection of books on all kinds of
subjects the shop became a sort of
cultural center where writers
politicians and other personalities of
the day came to meet at crce and model
FIFA and add up mithun or decide among
them was former Iraqi Prime Minister
Nouri aside and senior ministers of
government admitted here and add a pea
alfalfa Lee's is a treasure trove of
documents pictures and books that can't
be found anywhere else in McDevitt edema
jus den da shop is very old and it
houses a lot of old works via McDevitt
nahin Amitabh Lee's RB John Digges yo
this is a book by commander James Felix
Jones yo sup alfonsina I'd get up this
edition was published in eighteen fifty
seven jitesh etiquette India video asset
Jones was one of the first people to
survey what is now Iraq you said it
within yourself alphonse the book
contains rare maps of Iraq and Baghdad's
old town i'ma not about that akadema how
here we have the region of summer up
well I the month defend this is another
region there are even color pictures and
maps and studies of Iraqi tribes and
Baghdad's old town la raza Camilla a
shower wall- edema
the shops books and pictures are
especially important for anyone
interested in the social history of
Baghdad the photographs of street life
have become important sources for many
websites history buffs and people
looking to find out more about the
city's past level sword ali ahmad you
the end the year for luck that most of
the pictures i have shown baghdad in the
old days a little swap yeah I sorta
India Maru but in here this one is my
favorite it shows the flood of 1954 in
the city's Alawi district I remember it
at that time we lived in our car we
drove over to the area in the car why
did you find it people even drove there
from distant places like bars ahana and
Doreen Mahad Academy this rare photo
shows the town center of academia it was
taken in 1920 madhumathi and linearity
and baghdad essaouira only muhammad
akmal Maliki this is an interesting
photo from when the country was still a
monarchy it's a portrait showing Queen
Alia Prince Abdullah and King Faisal in
1947 our body
Oh
people returning to Iraq from abroad
often come here searching for pictures
of how Baghdad looked when they left so
much has changed and so much now looks
unfamiliar alpha filiz collection helps
them find the past again a source of
information without which many would be
lost el estado Kabam happy at the
telegram is a sensitive man he cares
less about business and more about
culture and the past after 2003 many
Iraqis return to Baghdad from abroad
mcdonough shall be all about of you
tomorrow morning he was aware that many
once familiar landmarks had disappeared
but the people who had come back we're
still looking for traces of what they
remembered to initiate the colonel well
my luck with many of them want to stay
in Iraq eminently possible missile Ohio
bday Huckabee that prompted Akram to
gather material pictures of Iraq and
Baghdad and copy and catalog them well
Bob dl e be de hockey kissimmee algunas
de genève june according people come
here to browse every day we get
monarchists then anti-monarchists each
to his own haha many of the stories they
tell have to do with the King's
grandfather father and mother and get
ahead it's why I knew I was all snotty
you want you could base entire books on
the stories told here and then I saw a
limo do then
the alfalfa Lee book shop specializes in
works that deal with various eras and
governments and tell the stories of
politicians as well as famous characters
Anya and the ugly melodic Mahad other
let me hamburg on I've got material on
just about anywhere in the city all the
important buildings I was a daffodil and
I have different archives dealing with
ministers presidents and the Iraqi royal
family haha and I also have another
archive for prime ministers and one more
covering the mayors of Baghdad I see you
I would sort oh my god Asselin
documenting history is important to make
sure people don't forget their past
without books and pictures there would
be no way to past our memories to the
generations to come an important effort
now how do you breathe fresh life into a
small town that's a problem facing novia
scarp it's a town located in western
Bulgaria north of the capital sofia
officials there wanted to give the
central square a modern touch and
decided to take an unusual approach they
turned a classic car into an open-air
display the vintage model they chose was
one of the most successful exports of
the former East Germany and it since
become a collector's item jivko
constantino from Nova TV has more the
plant that gave us the fourth board car
opened more than a century ago in the
German city of isin ah
the car was named after the town's
castle made famous by richard wagner's
opera thanh heuser
you
I doubt the man who created the vaad
book ever imagined the car would become
a flowerpot he dances of Toby Warren the
idea was born out of a desire to do
something different in our town we
wanted to change the appearance of the
town square we looked around at various
scrap yards and found the car this vaart
fog was made in 1965 with the help of
local residents and businessman we
achieved this result Masinissa grozny
business until of metal that an artist
was hired and in less than a week the
fart board became an artwork
professionals pumped on k2e daya the man
named the car was a spontaneous idea
young painting cars is nothing new for
me but it was the first time I'd painted
one as a flower pots in the automobile
we had some idea of how we wanted to
paint it but much of the design was
spontaneous um no mock way we wanted
something colorful and spectacular we
didn't spend that much time thinking
about it the colors had to suit the fact
that it's basically a car transformed
into a flower pot by the nebula sixth
year in the past owning a car like this
was a great luxury people had to wait
years for the chance to buy one nowadays
it's rare to see a really well
maintained fart book nostalgia is
helping to preserve the cars and to
revive interest in
I me the men bashing the work that isn't
about you why the vibe book well I
thought it would be interesting to use a
retro model because this kind of art
usually involves modern cars her
acquittal I thought the Varberg would be
appreciated by more eccentric people and
it was real challenge why not the vaad
book it's a very beautiful car yes I
hope people like it it shows old cars
don't have to be consigned to the
scrapyard they can be reinvented a fresh
idea indeed now to a product you might
have seen in the store before shea
butter it's a yellowish fat that comes
from the nut of what else the shade tree
which is indigenous to Africa in Mali
the production of shea butter is a
central part of life and for a group of
women we meet in our next story it's the
only means of survival un TVs Scott
Corbin and fiery dune himani show us how
an international effort to improve shea
butter production there has had a ripple
effect on local communities women like
these in Malley know all about the
benefits of the shade tree like
thousands of others they've been
gathering its fruit for years to produce
soaps and various products to sell now
production hovers at 80,000 tons per
year but it has the potential to reach
250,000 tons and improve lives I mean I
won yday do bo banna we faced two major
problems here the water situation and
the fact we have to do everything by
hand the lava men a trois reworks in
Cebu in southern Molly at the sebel in
ba cooperative the center uses 800
liters of water daily pumped from the
ground it's fetched by local women an
energy-sapping process leaving them too
tired to process Shea fruit
ing sirota mazzini solo y el Mar
boobarella but if we had the right
equipment and the water was nearer if we
fake a barakato me a cigar kiss away
then you would save time and increase
production la fille du khabar back in a
dilly I a new project run by the
governments of Mali and Luxembourg
together with the united nations
industrial development organization
unido is helping women in Malley to do
just that at this Center on the
outskirts of de ella new machinery and
improved production methods have
substantially increased outputs and
workers earnings a year ago the center
could only produce 100 kilos of soap per
day now it produces six times that
amount higher productivity and quality
means higher wages for the workers
allowing women to spend more money where
it matters now classrooms at local
schools in douala like this one are full
because parents no longer need their
children at the factory abdoulaye Tom
Cara headmaster at the dee wallace
school and irritable azam found a local
they no longer take the children out of
school the family income has increased
mana now with the meal machines does are
no longer made to do it and some they
can study normally in class in fact they
are the best performance LMAO solovey so
are their mothers who are striving hard
to produce the best shape products
Minister for the promotion of women
children in the family doctor qunari
Miriam
at tulane evil from the north to the
south and from the east to the west
women produce all kinds of sheer
products today what you are trying to do
is to look at the quality of share
products and improve it to the new
techniques technically the new products
target not only domestic consumers soaps
itself or just 50 euro cents in the
capital bamako are now being sold for
ten times more in Western countries this
shipment of 20 tons of soap is the first
delivery for a new client in France a
factory in Marseille owned by the
project's French partner the savona he
Jimmy D it has now formed a joint
venture with the DL abased cooperative
rather than by the raw material it's
choosing to buy a semi refined product
from Mali president of the sea arey wah
production center in douala diarra
dejara den bleh haces a phlebotomist
we've received training and increased
our knowledge and become much more
business-minded we buy the share and
transform it here and sell it for a
greater profit it's completely changed
our way of doing things theory if the
improvements here in deep Walla can be
extended across the country many more
women in Mali will stand to benefit from
this successful business model now
studying abroad it's something millions
of university students do every year
crossing oceans and continents to study
in a completely different country in a
different language often felt paraiso is
one of chile's biggest tourist cities
and it has several major universities so
it's no wonder that plenty of foreign
students end up there every year many of
them go to the city's Catholic
University ucv TVs milena Rodriguez has
a story
it's the beginning of another day in
Valparaiso the streets begin to fill
with people some of them seem anxious or
in a hurry while others are blinking in
the morning light after having pulled
another all-nighter these are the city
students many have come from abroad in
order to immerse themselves in another
culture explore the city and get to
grips with a new education system yes
hello Valparaiso por ti yo either they I
decided to come to Valparaiso because
other students who had studied here in
previous years told me it was a very
beautiful city by the sea with the
diverse culture and lots of students
daughter justice to the empties they
said you could live here very
comfortably well I suppose I leave our
kiddos I was surprised to see how
flexible the professors are ya 6 on
fitters you they give foreign students a
lot of help and offer lessons to those
who haven't yet mastered Spanish no he
came as a nice surprise at the start of
the year empezamos el ano participar de
una clase con muchos estudiante taking
part in a course with international
students as i like to call them is a
unique experience because it gives
chilean students the opportunity to
experience intercultural communication
right here y ESO hour in which is him up
a bit diva that's how I'd summarize it
one of the earth a diverse women there's
a unique atmosphere here in Valparaiso
last semester I was fortunate in a one
in three of my students came from abroad
a lot of new friendships are forged here
the program enables us to gain a better
sense of the world and allows the
foreign students to discover more about
us the people who live at the end of the
world Coronado so TRO Kate amo el final
de la dia
under the current education system
cultural exchanges between different
countries are becoming more and more
common it's an effective way for
students to widen their perspectives
experience a new culture and see the
world from other points of view
valparaiso has become a highly sought
after destination and not just because
of the quality of the education that it
offers but also because it's an
attractive port city students are drawn
by its bohemian feel and it's colorful
vibe yeah look on the talk to former
students who had been to valparaiso they
convinced me telling me it was a lovely
City I wanted to come to Latin America
and this was a good opportunity no well
guess Ian so I see that a city of many
colors it's impressive the architecture
isn't all the same everything is really
diverse and breathtaking Weaver MP is
increasing empty do not tumble paraiso
suva when you're in valparaiso standing
on a hill and looking out over the
Pacific the horizon looks as if it never
ends saucer caliber with all the chili
when we're close to the capital city of
chilly but not in it people here are
very warm-hearted Lima mine we're still
close to the bustling capital donde
donde esta la gran Ciudad chilena que la
capitale the university's exchange
program is going from strength to
strength as more and more students from
around the world find themselves drawn
to this charming city by the sea
and finally to Pakistan the province of
Balochistan directly borders Afghanistan
and it's a region that's often
associated with terrorism tribal
conflict and militancy but it's also
earned another distinction it's home to
one of the country's best cricket
players nahida come plays for Pakistan's
women's team and she hails from the city
of Coweta the largest in Balochistan
that's especially remarkable because
where she comes from women are rarely
given the opportunity to get involved in
sports nahida hasn't just gotten
involved though she's helped the
national team score some important
victories black box sounds sent us this
report the years eve vertical women play
cricket just as well as men we prove
this at the 2010 asian games both teams
were there the women and the men's the
men well they were there but we came
back with gold teeth Grey tea mera naam
nada my name is nahida Khan and I come
from quetta currently I'm completing a
master's in physical education and
sports science I'm on the Pakistan
national women's cricket team I
represent our country pakistan vimentin
key reminder geekery we just starts a
cricket cabal child I used to play in
the streets with my brothers and other
children from the neighborhood girls in
my college played cricket I joined them
and started playing qualys naval video
by soon I was selected for the
Balochistan women's cricket a me beside
que la start kiya though maybe selection
August when I was selected I initially
faced problems like phooey Thor this is
a conservative society but my father
supported me he was behind me all the
way Holy Ark I didn't give up I
continued playing support here mera
saath diya aur mein abhi him at me I did
well locally and was selected to play at
international level mr. Clerval potosi
been up in their backs on diamond
cricket team aamir selection who we
sub civility of my achievements is a
member of the women's cricket team
include participating in the 2009 icc
cricket world cup fixture against
australia later our side went on to win
the gold medal at the 2010 asian games
odd a beauty saintly i was also on the
team for the world cup qualifier held in
bangladesh it's movie where of deem gai
saathi am irrefutably my favorite player
is shahid afridi his style is aggressive
and he plays with confidence he starts
hitting boundaries as soon as he starts
playing i beat he's won lots of matches
for Pakistan I want to play like him too
and god willing I will see each other k
loogie nahi dejando hamari mashallah
international variable ajita come from
Balochistan province represents our
country internationally as a ski board
but this is a matter of great pride for
Balochistan despite the fact that young
women from the province don't get many
opportunities to prove themselves she
has attained the highest levels of
success through sheer hard work maganda
ponte a bj say when java parts of
Pakistan like the provinces of cinder
Punjab have good facilities in separate
grounds for women but in Balochistan the
situation is very different we face
problems due to the lack of grounds and
training academies the biggest problem
is not having a place to practice so
that I must lay here I can make it a
yoga practice cuddle
look so must think it people think
Balochistan is a provincial sort of
place and that we can't produce good
talent but I say if Balochistan can
produce great athletes like jahangir
khan and John Shere Khan then it has the
capability to create more corny concept
ecumenical SATA Pakistan killer you go
get my message to pakistani girls is
work with your parents to develop your
talents and build up your confidence I
too faced a lot of problems but I
believed in myself I managed to overcome
all the obstacles and continue playing
so may appear to be Muslim our sales in
the kelty I i put my problems to one
side and continued playing which is why
i achieved success ltd or seem em
economia Yogi's an inspiring story well
that's all this for this week's edition
of world stories from us our reporters
and partner stations around the world we
want to thank you for watching to watch
more episodes head to our website that's
DWD forward slash world stories will
leave you with this week's picks of the
world see you next time with more world
stories
you